-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
At home, if you're watching --
Look at you.
It is a -- It's a special night
because, for the first time
since the pandemic,
our audience is no longer
required to wear a mask.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Smile!
You're on TV.
Yeah.
So, you better laugh
'cause I can see who isn't.
[ Laughter ]
What an exciting time this is.
We're maskless,
fully vaccinated,
and it's officially summer.
Official.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's great.
That's right. Kids are pumped
that school is over
while their parents are staring
blankly at a wall like,
"I thought we had more time."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, and it's not just the
start of summer, you guys.
It's also Amazon Prime Day.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Today, instead of buying stuff
we don't need,
we buy stuff we don't need
at a slightly lower price.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what
an immersion blender is,
but, yeah, just look at
the price on that.
How am I gonna make my coffee
if I don't have
an immersion blender?
[ Laughter ]
Prime Day
is actually a two-day event.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, Amazon is basically
your annoying friend
who plans a birthday weekend.
[ Laughter ]
"You only get one day, Carl."
Yep, Amazon has deals
on outdoor cameras,
digital recorders,
and night-vision binoculars.
And with that much
spying capability,
you're basically Amazon.
[ Laughter ]
You're at least Facebook.
Some news from Washington.
This weekend, Kim Jong-un
made his first statement about
the Biden administration,
saying that he's prepared for
both dialogue and confrontation.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Kim Jong-un just challenged
Biden to a rap battle.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Kim Jong-un says that he's
prepared for both dialogue
and confrontation.
It's the same thing my aunt says
when she walks into a T.J. Maxx.
[ Laughter ]
"Let's go!"
Well, guys, the Olympics
are almost here, and today,
organizers announced that venues
will be at 50% capacity.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right. 50%,
which means only four people
will be allowed to watch fencing
instead of the normal eight.
[ Laughter ]
En garde!
-Chh!
-Do they start
with the hand up here?
-Sure. Why not?
Yeah.
-Eventually -- I've seen this.
-Eventually, it's épée.
-But does it start --
Like this, maybe?
-Yeah, maybe that.
Maybe that.
That looks good.
You look good like that.
-I look like a fencer there.
-Yeah, a fencer
of stolen jewelry.
-Just being cocky.
[ Laughter ]
-You got to put a pinky out
on the sword.
-Yeah, I throw the pinky out.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, class.
There you go.
-Class it up a little bit.
-Pure class.
-Pinky out on the sword.
Like that?
Maybe like that?
-Yeah, like a flourish.
-Like a flour--
-Like jazz hands.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
-This is how you fence?
-Yeah.
♪♪
-That's how you fence?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
En garde!
Touché!
-Also, they also said fans
aren't allowed to cheer.
-Oh.
[ Light laughter ]
-Although they say that at the
beginning of every graduation,
and parents are still like,
"Thomas, yeah!
Whoo!
Tommy, you did it!
That's my boy, Tommy!"
[ Laughter ]
Soccer superstar
Cristiano Ronaldo just became
the first person in the world
to hit 300 million followers
on Instagram.
-Ooh.
[ Cheers ]
-It's a pretty big deal.
and now a lot of people
are reaching out
to congratulate him.
For example, Lionel Messi said,
"What an incredible achievement.
Way to go!"
[ Laughter ]
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson said,
"Congrats, pal,
but watch your back.
I'm coming for you."
[ Laughter ]
Then Ronaldo himself
had this to say.
He said, "I can't believe it.
Thank you so much
for the support."
[ Laughter ]
It didn't stop there.
Remember that statue of him?
-I knew it.
I knew it.
-Oh, no, it didn't --
-The bronze statue of Ronaldo
reached out and said...
-Really?
-"Ermagherd, yer nermber wern!"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-After that, Ariana Grande said,
"I hope I can get
to 300 million soon."
And the statue of Ronaldo
was like, "Mer ter!
Er werna ber perpyerler!"
[ Laughter ]
Wants to be "perpular."
-"Perpular"?
-Then this plaque
of Elvis Presley spoke up
and said, "Yerr! Plers ferler
mer ern Ernstagrerm."
[ Laughter ]
And finally this statue
of Lucille Ball said,
"Mer herndle ers
@rerl-lercerlle-berl.
#Ferlerberk.
#Ernflererncer."
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're all very excited.
Good for him.
300 million is
nothing to sneeze at.
Listen to this.
I saw that NASA is struggling
to fix a computer on
the Hubble Space Telescope
that was developed in the 1980s.
Yeah.
It's from the '80s,
so the manual only says,
"Remove the circuit board
and blow on it."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a grocery store in
Wisconsin is offering customers
color-coded bracelets to show
their social-distancing
comfort levels.
Yeah, red means no contact.
Yellow means elbows only.
And green means open-mouth kiss.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
As I mentioned,
today is Amazon Prime Day.
People buy a ton of products
on Prime Day,
but you can't always
trust the reviews.
I just want
to remind everyone of that.
I read that lately Amazon had to
crack down on the fake ones.
Luckily, you can usually tell
when a review is fake, though.
For example,
here's a bed tray table.
Here's a fake review that says,
"I love this
for breakfast in bed."
The real review says,
"I love feeling like
my bedroom's in a hospital."
[ Laughter ]
-That's the real review?
-Yeah, like here's a pack of
anti-chafing nipple guards.
[ Laughter ]
The fake review says, "Provides
great protection on long runs."
The real review says,
"Ripping these off
is the male equivalent
of childbirth."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next is a Teton Sports
hiking backpack.
Fake review says,
"A rugged backpack
that's perfect
for overnight hikes."
The real review says,
"It'll sit in your closet
for three years
with a half eaten Clif bar
in the front pocket."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's where I left
that Clif bar.
Next up, here's an
Astro gaming headset.
The fake review says,
"Amazing sound.
Took my online gaming
to the next level."
But the real review says,
"Plays so loud, I didn't hear
my girlfriend say,
I'm leaving you, Kevin."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"He's hiding, he's hiding,
he's hiding!"
Finally, here's a waterproof
phone pouch.
Fake review says,
"Kept my phone safe and dry
while I went in the water."
Real review says, "My phone
is at the bottom of a lake,
but at least
it's still working."
[ Laughter ]
There you go, everybody.